Hola Muchas gracias por invitarme estuvo
increíble la presentación le hicimos
ayer a las seis de la tarde en el teatro
Heredia que es un teatro gigantesco
estuvieron más de quinientas personas y
fueron seis historias de toda América
Latina con ayudas audiovisuales
de todo tipo animaciones ilustraciones
más el audio y la narración entonces
creo que fue un éxito la gente del
festival va a escuchar autores
latinoamericanos y bien sea de ficción o
no ficción con su presentación los
periodistas también fueron protagonistas
Cómo fueron recibidos por el público
increíblemente realmente bueno mucha
gente no nos conocía otros sí Pero ha
sido un éxito total hemos estado ya en
varios festivales del del festival
estuvimos en Querétaro en Arequipa y
ahora en en Cartagena y y la acogida fue
Fue increíble
a través de sus podcast Durante los
últimos 10 años radio ambulante ha
propuesto más de 200 historias a través
de América Latina qué nos dicen esas
historias del continente
muchas cosas es un es una región muy
diversa pero a la vez muy similar creo
nos une Pues un idioma claramente
pero pero la idiosincrasia también es es
muy propia de la región no entonces
siento que cuando nosotros lanzamos el
proyecto una de las preocupaciones que
tenían algunas personas que no conocían
bien de que iba el proyecto era que de
pronto alguien de México no iba a estar
interesado en la historia de Argentina o
viceversa y lo que hemos demostrado a
través de estos diez años es que
precisamente una buena historia Es
Universal y y las historias humanas que
contamos nosotros en voz de los
protagonistas
conmueven profundamente y son muy
íntimas y son retratos de la región como
muy complejos que nos unen y que nos
demuestran como la cantidad de
similitudes que tenemos